ich habe mir die armen Viertel von Dubai
angeschaut um dort ein Video zu drehen
ja diese gibt es denkt man an Dubai
kommen einem zunächst vermutlich eher
solche Bilder in den Kopf hohe
Wolkenkratzer schnelle Autos und jede
Menge Luxus es gibt allerdings auch
Viertel wie Dubai dera hier im
Fischerdorf hat irgendwann mal alles
angefangen und durch das
Wirtschaftswachstum den Tourismus und
und und sitzt das Geld heutzutage
allerdings in anderen Teilen der meacity
und Viertel wie Dubai dera verfallen in
Armut in dera leben ausschließlich
Gastarbeiter die meisten aus Indien und
Pakistan hier kann man schon für
umgerechnet 3 € im Restaurant satt
werden wohl gemerkt mit Getränk ich habe
zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben
afghanisches Essen probiert war echt
ganz lecker in Dubai Downtown ist man da
mindestens das zehnfacher los außerdem
gibt es super viele kleine Elektroläden
mir wurde z.B ein iPhone 14 pro neu
verpackt für erechnet 926 € Angeboten
bisschen dubios aber deutlich günstiger
als hier in Deutschland die Menschen in
Dubai dera sind wirklich unfassbar
freundlich und auch als Tourist fühlt
man sich dort wohl es war genau die
richtige Entscheidung mein letzten Tag
in Dubai dort zu verbringen und nicht
auf die nächste überteuerte rooftopb zu
fahren um eine Shisha zu rauchen für
weitere Reisevideos aus aller Welt von